I'm here at the Autodesk Gallery today in San Francisco. There are some really
great objects here that have been made with the aid of computer graphics. Jesse
Harrington Au is here today to explain what these objects are about. So Jesse,
first of all, what's your background? &gt;&gt; : So, my background's actually in
industrial design. A long time ago, I was an illustrator. And then I started
doing these crazy exhibits, and weird things in warehouses. Started getting
involved very early on in the maker movement and then went back to school for
industrial design. Started doing product design, then do a little exhibit design
and that's fortunate enough to get picked up by autodesk. And where I get to
make a bunch of cool stuff around young entrepreneurs everyday in a place called
tech shop.